eric zemmour ou toute personnalité ou
toute personne peut aller se recueillir
rendre hommage évidemment j'ai aux
victimes des attentats et ensuite d'une
certaine manière toutes les questions
sont légitimes d'ailleurs elles sont
posés actuellement depuis des semaines
dans le cadre du procès des attentats du
13 novembre par les avocats des parties
civiles par les représentants des
victimes par les avocats aussi des
accusés parce que nous sommes dans un
état de droit suit d'ailleurs à une très
longue enquête des juges d'instruction
où nous tous les informations ont été
données et puis la presse le parlement
les responsables publics peuvent poser
des questions et les responsables de
l'époque doivent répondre à ces
questions françois hollande l'a fait il
ya quelques jours
dans la salle d'audience et je le ferai
moi-même aussi dans quelques mois mais
après je sais bien que ça n'a plus
beaucoup d'importance aujourd'hui mais
il ya il ya la décence ou même j'ai été
marqué après les propos d'eric zemmour
phares les les réactions des
associations de victimes parce que ce
procès leur appartient mais et les
victimes n'appartiennent à aucun
responsable politique donc chercher la
polémique crée la polémique c'est une
stratégie pour être présent dans le buzz
de la delà de la campagne électorale
pour provoquer dans un moment peut-être
dia est ce qu'on peut faire du buzz et
nissan ont
d'ailleurs on peut faire du buzz d'une
certaine manière surtout on le sait bien
mais sur ce sujet l'arrêt c'est qu'il ya
autant de morts autant de victimes
autant de blessés d'abord c'est inexact
ce qui a été dit
c'est honteux alors parce qu'il m'a de
gestion criminels quand il parle de
gestion qu'il
parlait de gestion criminelle est dire
donc que nous avons privilégié l'entrée
des migrants en europe et donc des
terroristes qui se serait où se sont
infiltrés dans les rangs des migrants au
détriment de la sécurité des français
c'est sait si on peut vous savez il ya
eu encore un attentat hier à la lumière
poule sans doute tous les pays de
l'europe puis de la planète mais tous
les pays de l'europe ont été rap slr
année par le terrorisme c'est soit un
terrorisme nationalistes on pense aux
basques ou ou à l'irlande ce sont soit
des français qui nous frappe et qui
n'ont pas eu besoin d'aller en syrie en
irak on l'a vu encore ces derniers mois
soient cédés ça a été le cas de groupes
organisés par des shs de manière
systématique pour frapper la france la
belgique la grande-bretagne ou
l'allemagne donc c'est un poil un d'une
très grande complexité moi je comprends
qu'on interroge l'état mais il ya une
chose que je veux dire est que je sais
c'est que ceux qui ont gouverné la
france depuis des années ont tout fait
et mettre tous les moyens sur une
situation très difficile pour protéger
les français des attentes à sion éviter
des attentats ont eu lieu si les
attentats ont lieu c'est qu'il ya eu des
failles c'est qu'il ya eu des échecs
mais dire que nous avons une
responsabilité directe d'une certaine
manière volontaire dans ce qui s'est
passé c'est insupportable et cela montre
le niveau de campagne et la violence que
veut provoquer eric zemmour dans le dans
le débat alors vous lui diriez quoi eric
zemmour soir si mais quand on aspire
c'est sa légitimité sans doute à vouloir
présider au destin de ce grand pays
qu'est la france qui est le pays
d'europe le plus touché par les attaques
terroristes et pourquoi
parce que nous sommes la france parce
que nous sommes une république laïque
parce qu'il les voit l'ailé loi sur
l'interdiction des signes religieux à
l'école et du voile intégral dans
l'espace public parce que nous sommes un
pays aux traditions chrétiennes parce
que nous sommes le pays où il ya la
première communauté juive d'europe parce
que nous sommes le pays où l'islam est
la deuxième religion du pays parce que
nous sommes un pays qui défend les
valeurs universelles et qui assume ses
responsabilités dans le monde nous
sommes attaqués par cela donc
tenir ce propos divisé m avec cette
violence telle responsabilité sur le
président à publique de l'époque
françois hollande nom pourrait le faire
aussi sur nicolas sarkozy à propos de d
attente à toulouse et monte en moi je me
suis toujours refusé surtout sur les
questions du terrorisme a brisé un
moment où l'autre l'unité est cassé et à
briser toute tentative d' unité
nationale sur un sujet aussi grave qui
est on a attaqué la france parce que
nous sommes la république laïque et
parce que nous sommes toujours pays des
valeurs il faut trop bon
on